a random shooting police say in our area
ended up with some arrests in arizona
these thanksgiving shootings in
henderson led up to a
shootout with police 8 news now's david
charns tells us what investigators know
right now
i heard a gunshot and echoed into the
whole
neighborhood melissa wells says she was
getting ready for bed early thanksgiving
morning
when she heard gunshots not even 30
seconds later i heard maybe three more
gunshots and then right after that
another sequence probably two or three
after that
and i'd say there was probably a total
of maybe 12 or 13.
those bullets hit at least five people
killing a 22-year-old man in
this parking lot here at 7-eleven at
lake mead in sunset
and then those suspects were on the run
according to police
the people in the car a man and a woman
described as having facial tattoos or
wearing face paint
then drove off sources tell 8 news now
the pair may be involved in more random
shootings about 150 miles away
in western arizona it was not far from
there they met up with police
who engaged in yet another shootout no
one in that shooting was hurt
and police say they took three people
into custody it's unclear though right
now how that third person
is involved we come into the store
almost daily
throughout the day thursday and friday
customers came in to check on staff here
though those staff members say they
could not talk about the incident
now because police tell us there were
several shootings before this young man
was killed in this parking lot and there
were reports
of gunshots around town they do want to
hear from any witnesses
you can call police directly or you can
report anything anonymously to crime
stoppers
we're at lake mead in sunset in
henderson i'm david charns 8 news now